we work in the dark
like hey guys don't want to do we are
assassins the film of Assassin's Creed I
just want it to be an unbelievable ride
that lead you into some action sequences
that are dynamic than they feel really
exciting and we're trying to base as
much as possible in reality
I'm Dave ultis understandable Michael in
the movie Michael Fassbender's character
is trapped and he has to jump a leap of
faith
jumping 125 feet normally it would be a
digital character that would jump off
Damien's
the best so we're going to do it for
real Justin wants it to be as real as
possible we're going to the real world
we're not relying on visual effects we
start off low with the first jump is
just a matter of figuring out the timing
at the free fall the actual footprint of
the bag is only 10 meters by 10 meters
so when you're up there it looks about
size of a four piece paper even vertical
7 feet
drop again
in the bag top-heavy so get a bit with
much on the back of head so I try and
not do that three two
that's the best bit when you walk off
and go I'm alright yeah
my you were executed and pronounced dead
you no longer exist what kind of prison
is this it's not a prison
you're about to enter the Animus what
you're about to see hear and feel are
the memories of your ancestor who has
been dead for 500 years what do you want
from me your past
welcome to the Spanish Inquisition
we work in the dark just sort of the
light we are assassins
Oh
the assassins are fighting for free will
and their main rivals are Templars and
Templars are trying to enhance humankind
through science
I think Assassin's Creed has a really
deep concept an idea which is going back
into time and having some sort of
relationship with the ancestor that's
come before you the overall journey of
the film is through the eyes of our
protagonist Scylla Michael Fassbender is
playing your past
he starts to learn that he comes from a
lineage of assassins
he realizes the true history of himself
and he creates a kind of revolution
the dark observe the right
we are assassins
michael is one of the greatest actors of
his generation and there's many other
strong characters in the film
the Assassin's Creed universe is a
cinematic experience action sequences or
massive I just want it to be an
unbelievable rot
have to show him who he really is
mine at 6:00 p.m. yesterday evening you
were executed and pronounced dead you no
longer exist what kind of prison is this
it's not a prison you're about to enter
the Animus what you're about to see hear
and feel are the memories of your
ancestor who has been dead for 500 years
what do you want from me
your past
welcome to the Spanish Inquisition I am
God even though I'm a man of God Oh
y'all better quit plan
we work in the dark a sort of delight we
are assassins
and
more more and more less probably more